[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
this is an open format type of segment
where we talk about updates on stories
we've talked about in the past or our
personal lives I have it I'm the only
one I just want to put it out there this
week I didn't make ramen for the first
time yeah it's [ __ ] bomb PFT I we
have wait no more war and history what
the blue married but they hang out more
than you guys listen here couch sack I
don't hear you this is what it is before
she's gonna have sack maybe when you
have sex you all I thought god this
morning I just want to punch her in her
ovaries listen you can't the sushi was
amazing
what sushi really good that was the
first by the way you tried that too no
no he made he made some sort of
variation with like yellow Julia just
stop Julia I'm share with you guys so
David on his channel has a mukbang cook
for his friends his friends Channel
right like I mean oh we're not friends
yet his friends listen you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] alright I'm knocking up your
included in that that are the easiest to
knock out first so Joe because he
revealed that he was Japanese I decided
to make sushi for him I contacted his
ass and said let's do it exactly so okay
listen listen to me you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ]
I made it her stuff because she's very
easy because I was already a Japanese
theme and she loves anime so I met her
anime dish so she's so easy why give her
a ramen dish okay there's some
complicated stinky tofu type [ __ ] I made
at ichiraku ramen from Naruto the anime
why she called you're jealous ass is
down oh yeah I'm hella jealous you so
jealous
you guys are left out because you're
very difficult because I'm trying to do
it like somatically I just the first of
all you like both you like sweets I'm
not very good at anything
I would like candy I don't like desserts
so much I like anything something very
creative for you to specifically very
creative especially because you guys are
[ __ ] bean pinto beans so like I'm
trying to like make it creative and fun
for me too so you got it a little bit
more tricky yeah you know KC every
pretty much every night he's been trying
to make something from that book I saw
oh where's the invite if I made juice
shabu and miso soup pork style yesterday
well what's the book you gave me again
the one we got him yeah yeah yeah what
did we get him so it's a book and with
movies and meals from the movies yeah
yeah where did we get it from [ __ ]
book store you know it's funny I kind of
gave him a little [ __ ] cuz he was like
cuz we he blogged it right he was like
yeah Barton Gio gave me his book and
then after I was like oh why are you
giving part credit you paid for half
fine what do we give Joe for Christmas
ah exactly what it's a fire surefire
thing a surefire huh it's not sure haha
sure to fire dry fire that fire it's
okay cuz Jill gave Jess a book and I was
like okay that book really helped you
owe me for the rest of your life no
really
but the point I was trying to make is
running is very difficult and also it's
kind of weird because after you make a
food you kind of realize like pricing
and disparity for example like Italian
food right Italian food I'm not saying
that it's not difficult I will say this
though it's not near as much work as
ramen but that's much preparation
exactly and people expect a bowl of
ramen to be eight dollars but they spend
the time for to be like 1600 ramen is
way crazier than doesn't even come close
to how difficult right I don't know
anything about specifically like it just
in a ramen restaurant alone right they
have four different products they have
four different products they have time
it's part of like the concentrated base
right exactly so therefore different
powders for whatever they're making
right and they have four different soup
processor that [ __ ] so it's like what
the [ __ ] man I don't know either way I
don't know if I'ma crumble that's
Japanese people's fall for making it so
damn cheap it's it there's a price of a
hamburger it's really achieved but it's
really complicated
Robin is like the hamburger for Japanese
ramen is really cool too because it's
not like traditionally like joe said -
we were talking about it yesterday it's
not traditionally Japanese so there
isn't really like this said thing about
this is how it has to be made so any
ramen shop that you go to they have
their version of what it is so it's like
for example like I made a shio ramen
right shio ramen just means salt so the
main flavoring just has to be salt that
arises at shio ramen so but you could
have it to be whatever you could
mushrooms whatever whatnot so the one I
made yesterday was a triple broth so it
was with dashi a chicken broth and then
as shiitake mushroom so it was a
mushroom seal ramen that I made and I
don't know somebody else has it but
that's how I made it anything's
perfectly fine you better cook for taiko
I will when he has teeth feeding them we
tried feeding him this week we did Oh
what did you try to feed him baby parrot
Puri no I made it Oh puree
we're a Gemini we see that Yuri I don't
know I didn't feel according to theory I
never heard somebody for nothing like
that before
said the guy who's Schneider he said he
was snared that's retired tonight so
it's tired I'm really sorry
yeah get off my back David all right
Puri Puri you take the so eating um so I
gave him a little bit he tried it and of
course we swallowed carrots by the way
and then in ninja'd magic bullet it was
a magic bullet but like baby bullets
it's really cute adorable if you like it
uh he was just like what the hell
this is McKenna I would I would put the
spoon right in front of him though like
not on his mouth but they need to look
at he's like alright I'll do the kid
thank you I know you were telling me
like he's totally not a scaredy cat
right he's like an adrenaline junkie
yeah so like these days I've been
dropping him in controlled fashion so
now that not in the social did you guys
know yes I let you guys know how did the
social service you mean fashion but in a
very controlled way just to see like I
want to test his boundaries so I have
them and then I like go like that for
like a foot and then like two feet in
the pretty soon if she doesn't come
downstairs yet then it turns into like a
[ __ ] like a bee a bumblebee around
the entire room and then when when I'm
moving him he just opens his mouth and
he gets really excited goes he's not a
little [ __ ] like me and David know I
can't handle that [ __ ] should be
absolutely terrible but did you guys
watch anybody up there
the Francis and Donna and focus the baby
it's like the only fine watch this year
so far I know cor meum
remember the remember uh Donald the guy
knocked out over him yeah but the
[ __ ] accidentally touching him yeah
so he fought the heavyweight champion
right up steep a mutual you see that the
the strongest puncher in the world yet
the strongest in the world in the world
yeah he set the record for however he's
a genious world of like did he make you
punching no there's a machine yeah yeah
no there's a machine but he set the
world record a punch drink and second
place is far below him and then third
fourth it so he's no interesting too
because he got so much hype in mind you
I love France and Ghana just because of
like how he's been knocking people out
and so he caught on everybody's radar
but then you have somebody like Steve
pay me a check right and then people
just we're kind of just like pushing him
aside they're like oh he's gonna get his
ass now
yeah so how can you so easily get his
ass knocked out this full steepy has
[ __ ] everybody up that has came in so
he's the only heavyweight champion that
has defendants bail three times
oh I mean history in USC oh sure so got
rating belts like crazy by the way yeah
everyone holds on wins it loses it wins
it it's hard to hold on the head weight
belt so in god it like magic he tagged
him up in that first round but like
everybody said and gone oh they don't
know how far he can go if he's going the
distance and you know heavyweights get
super tired right yeah so by the time
and by the way stevie has amazing ground
game and even like Joe Rogan talks about
this how important wrestling is and he
just [ __ ] him up for round two and
round three it was pretty [ __ ]
amazing and then Daniel Cormier [ __ ]
up volcanoes Damir in two rounds dude oh
yeah the first run he was already
supposed to beat up because he had he
had a rear naked choke on him and then
the round ended he was already to beat
him in the first round and the second
round he put him in a crucifix flattened
amount of started smashing his face in
oh this is the ref stop this so it was
the same [ __ ] like volcanoes Amir people
were talking about this guy as if he was
going to knock Daniel Cormier I'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me so if you
think that he's gonna be Daniel Cormier
that means that volcano Zamir can beat
John Jones yeah so if you look at it
like that it's like skill levels here
yeah I mean Daniel Cormier was just
laughing he goes there's levels to this
game and you know what his mind he goes
if i if john jones beats me that means
you can be john jones you're not gonna
touch me knocking about - well it was
[ __ ] amazing I have no idea it almost
always may be you know what I did you
know you tell me you recently talked
about these okay so this is like a me to
thing yeah it's not really hey you guys
so it's it kind of went not as big as
everybody else's just because it's a
little it's [ __ ] right and he's
friendly so there's so you know at least
right here this is really about that
meat to move in and he's supposed to be
like this guy who's a relationship
doctor now this girl came out oh wait
Aziz is a relationship guru kind of yes
so he published author you guys could
read his books and everything else guys
but either way who's a foodie - um he's
a foodie so he mounted a date with this
girl right long story short you guys
could read about it later do you know
don't take my word for everything um
they met he kind of ignored her at first
and so this girl apparently they were at
a party it might have been the golden
little party or something like that she
had a date ditched her date went to go
follow his ease right he kind of brushed
her off saw his camera they connected
changed numbers met up after went on a
date so went on a date everything was
going fine went up to their room he
minded her over she came over they
started making out long story short she
says she felt uncomfortable whole time
didn't tell him it all and he went down
on her she gave him like to blow jobs
they [ __ ] and everything else and then
afterwards she texts him say hey like I
felt really uncomfortable he texted her
back saying I'm sorry I didn't know that
you felt that way that wasn't my
intention I thought we were having a
good time like if you ever felt that way
he apologized straight up and but after
where she said that basically he he
sexually assaulted her Oh regretting sex
with someone is not the same and
everybody is on that same same page too
and I think like the only thing that
that I guess you could really tag him
for is the fact that he you know for a
guy who talks about understanding like
cues and stuff really didn't get it so
he was doing like some weird [ __ ] like
sticking his finger in her mouth and my
fingering her and [ __ ] and then I think
like it was kind of like that type of
sex that you see a guy that just watches
too much porn at the end of the day
everybody is on his either side saying
like how can you be a part of this me -
movement when it was consensual you went
up to his room you didn't tell him to
stop so he thought it everything was
fine yeah you gave him a [ __ ] which
he didn't grab your head yeah giving a
[ __ ] is kind of like hey I'm
interested it's really personal
yeah it's size that we communicate it's
it's it's on a first date I think it is
feel like a [ __ ] is like it's a is a
nice act of service especially if you do
two of them how do you give to [ __ ]
they sit like one and then two or is it
like one and then [ __ ] and she licks
her vagina dick on got it - man I
haven't read the little story thing I
just kind of got
some of like the gist of what was
happening and to me it just seems like
wait why is this being blown out so
crazy if it doesn't seem like he had
like ill intentions he did it so and the
publication got a lot of [ __ ] from it so
you can see it on there instead then
they shape it like it's a way that they
shape it they really try to make it come
out as AI person who was like sexually
assaulting nurse like I felt really
uncomfortable people read between that
[ __ ] they're like hold on a second
you gave him consent throughout the
whole thing yeah you know you didn't
tell that's the main thing there exactly
and so there people are reading it like
oh why are you trying to vilify this
human being you know it was a bad date
and maybe he's not that great he's
really [ __ ] awkward to be honest with
you when you read it but it doesn't make
him this like sexual offender yeah I'm
saying and so it just kind of blew out
of proportion and I think like the the
problem with that is that everybody is
trying to be a part of this like new
rhetoric of me too but you have to be
very important about the stories that
you tell you know this is not a me-too
movement type of thing so like you're
trying to compare this like Kim
Kardashian when she came out she put
hashtag me too she got roasted she did
yeah you mean about the Ray J thing on
Twitter so she put list you wanted to be
a part of the me tube movie but she got
destroyed cuz she benefited Frogs a
quoting her sexuality Ray J just wanted
to be a part of it she's just like oh
what oh she just fired them with hash
tagging me to she's like oh me too oh I
was just like in support of the movement
but you can't it's weird when you put
yourself on the forefront of a movement
when you were actually on the opposite
side where you [ __ ] your way to the top
you got to have sexual street cred yeah
and so like I be a poser and so like I
guess like the the one thing that people
are talking about to her credit is to
say that there isn't really this
conversation about like teaching people
how to interact with somebody in this
type of situation you know what I mean
nonverbal cues to me I don't really go
with it like I believe that if you have
this responsibility of saying hey I'm a
woman and I want I want to be taken
seriously and I want people to
understand that I'm I'm in control of my
own world then that goes that goes both
ways right so if you don't say something
that also means that you're not in
control so it's like I when I say yes
you you listen to me when I say no you
listen to me but you didn't do that but
if you don't say anything at all no
one's gonna be able to assume exact
so then you're picking and choosing when
you want to play the victim card right
so it's like I want responsibility but
not in this case I don't want
responsibility I think that's what a
child does a grown woman can say no get
away peasant right but like teenage
girls and stuff they go oh my god what's
happening
I don't know right that's that's the
thing that's the difference between the
two is like if you're a grown-ass woman
and you you can't say no you can't blame
other people for doing good I mean I
hear what you're saying and I feel like
a lot of this stuff is when there's a
good abuse of power and that's when like
the women get taken advantage of yes
they're grown-ass women they can't say
no but then there's like the abuse of
power but there is no abuse a part of
this case because she she didn't in this
case there was no abuse of power because
there was nothing to gain for her but
sighs social currency for her right I'm
going out with disease
you know she ditched her date apparently
but it came out literally yeah the other
examples is just the guy straight up
grabbing over a titty you're gonna get
fired or showing up at her room butt
naked yeah like you mean like the
Weinstein it wasn't like this one that I
don't think it's abuse of power it's a
bad day yeah just a bad day and so the
problem with this too is that other
people who are defending her are trying
to make other women feel like hey you
know when you had a bad date before
that's actually sexual assault
so the turn change law this rhetoric I
mean so it's like so that's what a lot
of women are I've been reading up a lot
of comments it's like well why are you
telling me that I should feel like I got
sexually assaulted now from these
previously well you did you had this
experience to you actually got sexually
assaulted so you're trying to like
because when our first intimate time
like after the fact because it that
night I was really drunk and then after
the next morning I kind of felt like oh
[ __ ] like I should probably shouldn't
have done that and I was telling Casey
once I read the whole Aziz think we're
not fully but one suggests of it I was
like then that means then I technically
in those like in those terms and I was
sexually assaulted by you to like if
that's the way they're painting it which
I don't think it's fair because it's
like I fully consented to the whole
thing now you're married and in love
what is that it's like there's so many
positive things that come from this
sexual assault no that's not sexual
assault that's why that's what I'm
saying it's like how is that sexual
assault is trying to like change like
how and and I guess like other women who
were in for it they were saying oh
that's right you know when I went that I
guess I got sexually assaulted the line
notes getting too far out there where
now they're kind of losing the support
because of all this exactly and that's
like but my fear about it you don't know
sexually assaulted me
she kissed me first [ __ ] you are
horrible Jimmy asked Jimmy to even ask
for me oh you're welcome and I should
have said something but I couldn't say
yes or no did you show the tears after
after you cried afterwards yeah when I
do kissing this the kiss was a little
bit salty just a little bit Lepus
consent to his boner sucks when he gets
like this far out of hand because then
people start backtracking and
questioning questioning everything else
like wait is this valid then or like I
mean that's what I called the gray zone
because he like there's certain cases
where it's like oh yes I would apply and
no it wouldn't
yeah and so we needed like talk about
this too it's like people are trying to
get rid of this I don't say people but
these small sect of human beings want to
let go of this thing called personal
responsibility you have personal
responsibility is very [ __ ] important
so just because things go wrong you
can't just deflect it like you said
that's what children do yeah you know so
when you have this ability to say no he
could have left at any time he would
have never grabbed you he would have
never been upset he would just be like
ah [ __ ]
you know she's not into me and he would
could've walked out and people are some
people are just glazing over that you
know like well you know he obviously was
it doesn't matter if you say he's still
a person you know what I mean he wasn't
holding against her he was gonna give
her a job he wasn't giving her there was
nothing there it was just you went for a
date it didn't go out the way that you
wanted and you were in full control of
the situation
yeah
like he didn't show up to some awards
show but then James Franco ended up
getting an award and that same award
show and then people were like clapping
for him but when Izzy's name came up
like everyone was silent
I'm like James Franco's [ __ ] is way
worse there's like many women yeah
accusing him and like he has like a
history of like trying to get a 17 year
old to his hotel room and [ __ ] and I
think like this for reals
I've witnessed his sexual abilities I
know why or what anyway man it's all
funny so what do you see at the same
time James Franco did and me and Joe
used to study at the Starbucks that
James frankly study out all the time
yeah and then so at that Starbucks like
at that time I didn't understand when
they're famous like there's a certain
power or attraction that you have so it
was this very like curious watch from a
distance watch this powerful [ __ ]
magician work his magic and I'm there
studying by myself and every time this
fool comes to study he's always
surrounded with like eight hot girls in
a study group and they're all no one's
ever paying attention and this was
really trying to study because I'm
always eavesdropping he's like okay did
you try the literature degree or
whatever so he's really trying to talk
about English and all that and all the
girls like uh-huh yeah and every girl is
always trying to wear something sexual
like they're trying to seduce him and I
think they're all trying to see which
one's gonna stay there the longest and
no one wants to leave this is [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] lying it's just a really
weird situation man like I just I kind
of get caught up in like reading this
type of [ __ ] just because like I like I
like the me to blue is pretty dope you
know but then you just have like this
one outlier that's kind of trying to
like bend those rules over to make her
feel better about a choice and my choice
personal responsibility that you made
that you regretted later and on top of
that you [ __ ] out a disease is a
terrible dater it's like oh [ __ ] now
these girls know what he's gonna try to
do got rid of his game and it's just
like yeah yeah he did some weird [ __ ]
though like you like put his fingers in
her mouth if internal like fingers
is a freak I think I think he just sound
like a dude that just really I think the
guy probably never got [ __ ] pride to
him being famous
he just sounds like a freak but it was
like really awkward [ __ ] it's kind of
like stuff that you thought of like
doing when you were like a 12 year old
or 13 when you first watch porn yet I
mean not like oh [ __ ] bro like I thought
he would have been like a lot more
smooth you know but it was like [ __ ]
panty chasing around a counter come on
Aziz no man you're my hero bro oh let's
go [ __ ] it gel outfits like black and
white stripes oh yeah but he's like a
freak too cuz he was like saying some
weird [ __ ] to while he's like [ __ ]
her from behind this was like she was
like talking about as she was getting
plucked she saw a reflection and so
she's like getting hit from the back
like this right play he's really
enjoying it but I'm not yeah I don't
bite so the whole time you're getting
[ __ ] you like this is not that enjoyable
are you looking at this face well penile
he looks like this
[Music]
[Music]